she is the only one who can deliver a
message like this the queen telling
other world leaders they must act now
and not for their own sakes of course
the benefits of such actions will not be
there to enjoy for all of us here today
we none of us will live forever
but we are doing this not for ourselves
but for our children and our children's
children
and those who will follow in their
footsteps there was an added poignancy
because of the recent worries about the
queen's health which meant her family
had to support the prime minister in
welcoming leaders to glasgow as the
monarch via video message asked them to
put their differences to one side
i for one hope that this conference will
be one of those rare occasions
where everyone will have the chance to
rise above the politics of the moment
and achieve true statesmanship
a message praising prince philip's
commitment to conservation and prince
charles and prince william's
environmental work
came as her prime minister prepared to
announce the first major deal of cop 26.
with more than a hundred leaders
committing to end deforestation by 2030
from canada and russia to colombia
indonesia and brazil
a pledge which will restore degraded
land tackle wildfires and support
indigenous communities backed by almost
14 billion pounds in funding
forests absorb around one third of the
global co2 released from burning fossil
fuels every year but an area of forest
the size of 27 football pitches is lost
every minute brazil's greenhouse gas
emissions
increased in nine and a half percent
last year during the pandemic which is
odd and brazil was one of the only
countries in the world that saw that
increased because the economy stopped
right during the pandemic and that was
due to deforestation
with some at cop 26 already not going
far enough on their climate commitments
the announcement on forests will at
least be seen as one positive as the
world leaders meet for another day
rhiannon mills sky news in glasgow